michelle and i
are
happy to be here with such a
good-looking crowd
everybody's cleaning up nice
thank you to shaka fattah for
not just the great introduction but more
importantly your leadership especially
on
the issues of brain research that have
the potential to change so many lives
i want to thank shanice washington and
everybody at the cbc foundation
for doing so much to help all our young
people achieve their god-given potential
i see so many friends here tonight
and
obviously
these last
these last several weeks have been
momentous in a lot of ways
many of you i had an opportunity to see
both hosting at the white house but then
at
the actual
anniversary the 50th anniversary of the
march on washington
and it was a little rainy that day we
didn't have a nice roof over our heads
but
that wasn't enough to keep
all of you away it wasn't enough to keep
me away
it wasn't enough to keep folks from all
across the country from coming out to
pay tribute
to not only dr king not only
john lewis
not only
the well-known heroes of the civil
rights movement but to all the ordinary
americans who made it possible for so
many of us to stand here today
and as i looked out on that crowd
listening to
christine king ferris and reverend
lowery and
congressman lewis
it was impossible not to appreciate
just how much progress we've made
it was impossible not to think of all
the hearts that have been opened all the
laws that have been changed
all thanks to the quiet heroes who
refuse to give up or give in
and as i said on that day
to dismiss the magnitude of that
progress
to somehow suggest
that little has changed
dishonors the courage and the sacrifice
of all those who paid
the price to march in those years
but what i also say
and i think there wasn't a speaker
there that day or
on saturday
in the other commemoration of the march
who didn't make this point we would also
dishonor those heroes to suggest that
the work of this nation is somehow
complete
and that's something that the cbc has
always understood
it wasn't until 1969
six years after the march on washington
that african americans in congress
formed a caucus
and by then the civil rights act had
been passed the voting rights act had
been signed the civil rights movement
had been successful in many ways but the
men and women who founded this caucus
recognized what dr kigg understood
that equality
is not just an abstraction
it's not just a formality it has to go
hand in hand with economic opportunity
that in order to address the enduring
legacy of slavery and jim crow we've got
to make it easier for every american to
earn their piece of the american dream
so fast forward to today 50 years later
we all understand
we have to be vigilant against any
attempt
to roll back our hard-won civil rights
whether that means tearing down barriers
put up by those who seek to restrict the
right to vote
or making sure our criminal justice
system works equally well for everybody
not just for some
but at a time when black unemployment
remains twice as high as white
unemployment
at a time when working americans of all
races have seen their incomes and wages
stagnate even as corporate profits and
the incomes of folks at the very top are
soaring
we've got to pick up the torch of
economic justice
we have to make this a country
where anybody who works hard can earn
their way into the middle class
and until we do we will not let up and
we will not rest no matter how much
resistance we get we will keep on
pressing forward
because it's good for america
it's the right thing to do
we can't rest until every american
knows the security of quality affordable
health care
in just over a week
thanks to the affordable care act and
the leadership shown by the cbc and
others in congress
so many of you fought to pass this law
thanks to your efforts
six and ten uninsured americans
will finally be able to get covered for
less than a hundred dollars a month
everybody's gonna be able to get
coverage six and ten will be able to get
coverage for less than a hundred bucks a
month
and by the way the only reason it's six
and ten is because we got some governors
who
haven't seen the light yet
if every governor chose to join this
project rather than to
fight it just to score some political
points that number would be nearly eight
and ten
so so just think about that
knowing you can offer your family the
security of health care
that's priceless and now you can do it
for less than your cell phone bill
that's what change looks like
we won't rest until every american has
access to a good education
and we've got to make sure every child
every child gets the best start in life
we want to give every four-year-old in
america access to quality preschool
there's no better investment we should
be making it right now we can afford it
it's the right vision it's the right
time
we should make college
more affordable
for every family there's no better
ticket to the middle class in this
country
and we've already made college including
hbcus more affordable for millions of
students and their families through tax
credits and grants and student loans
that are going further than ever before
but
we got more to do and so i've i've been
talking to colleges
telling them they need to do their part
by bringing costs down because in a 21st
century economy a higher education is
not a luxury it is an economic
imperative and everybody should be able
to afford it not just a few
we can't rest until we offer new ladders
of opportunity
for anyone willing to climb them
when you think about america
when you think about the ideal
of this country
a big part of it is the idea of upward
mobility
the idea that if you work hard you can
get ahead well over the last 30 years
upward mobility in this country has
slipped out of reach for too many people
and that's especially true
in communities with
large african-american populations
so we've got to do more to rebuild
neighborhoods
help some of the hardest hit towns in
america get back on their feet
we've got to raise the minimum wage
nobody who works full-time in the
wealthiest nation on earth should have
to raise their children in poverty
those are fights we need to win
and finally we can't rest until all of
our children can go to school or walk
down the street free from the fear that
they will be struck down by a stray
bullet
just two days ago
in my hometown
chicago
13 people were shot during a pickup
basketball game including a
three-year-old girl
tomorrow night i'll be meeting in
mourning with families in this city
who now know the same unspeakable grief
of families in newtown and aurora and
tucson and chicago and new orleans and
all across the country
people whose loved ones were torn from
them without headlines sometimes or
public outcry but it's happening every
single day
we fought
a good fight earlier this year but we
came up short
and that means we've got to get back up
and go back at it because as long as
there are those who fight to make it as
easy as possible for dangerous people to
get their hands on gun then we've got to
work as hard as possible for the sake of
our children we've got to be ones who
are willing to
do more work to make it harder
these are the tasks before us
these are the challenges we face
it's a tall order all of it
i know the odds sometimes seem long
i i was taking photos with the cbc folks
every one of them came up said
oh you hang in there
you
you hang in there man
and i said
i said don't worry about me
i am still fired up
because i still see the work that needs
to be done
the work didn't go away
and part of the reason
that i don't get tired is because i've
seen
people who are in this audience and what
you've done the odds that you've
overcome
you know i know sometimes the climb
seems stiff at any given moment
sometimes it seems like the pettiness of
our politics just is making things worse
and worse you look at it right now
the other day house republicans voted to
cut 40 billion dollars in nutritional
aid for struggling families
at the same time as some of the same
folks who took that vote
are receiving subsidies themselves
so so farm subsidies for folks at the
top are okay
help feeding your child
is somehow not
i know the cbc led by
outstanding chairwoman marsha fudge
fought hard to protect those programs
that keep so many children from going
hungry
and now we're seeing an extreme faction
of these folks convincing their
leadership to threaten to shut down the
government
if we don't shut down the affordable
care act
some of them were actually willing to
see the united states default on its
obligations and plunge this country back
into a painful recession
if they
if they can't deny
the basic security of health care to
millions of americans
i think that this is an interesting
thing to ponder
that your top agenda
is making sure 20 million people don't
have health insurance
and you'd be willing to shut down the
government and potentially default
for the first time in united states
history
because it bothers you so much
that we're actually going to make sure
that everybody has
affordable health care
well let me
let me say as clearly as i can it is not
going to happen we have come
too far we've overcome far darker
threats than those
we will not negotiate over whether or
not america should keep its word and
meet its obligations we're not going to
allow anyone to inflict economic pain on
millions of our own people just to make
an ideological point and those folks are
going to get some health care in this
country we've been waiting 50 years for
it
it's time for these folks to
stop governing
by crisis
start focusing on what really matters
creating new jobs growing our economy
expanding opportunity for ourselves
looking after our children doing
something about the violence out there
as we've got
all these battles we have to face
we've got to remember what brought us
here in the first place
and as i was preparing my speech
for the anniversary last month i was
doing some research reading some stories
about
people who would come to the march 50
years ago and i came across the story of
a young man named robert avery
and and robert was 15 years old in 1963
so he and two friends decided to
hitchhike
from gadsden alabama
to the march on washington
and together they traveled through some
of the most segregated counties in
america
sleeping in bus terminals
eating from vending machines
sometimes not eating
sometimes they walked
sometimes passerbys
black and white offered them rides
worried that they might not make it on
their own
700 miles later
the boys from gadsden reached their
destination
they marched with dr king
and it left a mark on them
and afterwards robert went back home to
alabama
and he's now spent the last three
decades on the gadsden city council and
robert avery's here tonight
and
and in some ways robert's story is
duplicated all across this room
dr king talked about how
we're inextricably linked
robert kennedy talked about how
if you toss a pebble in a pond the the
ripples
emanate from that center and
and the same is true in our own lives
how those ripples of hope
we don't know
sometimes how they're going to have an
impact on folks later but
all those tiny ripples build up
and end up
changing the world
so when i think about robert avery in
the city council and i'm sure he's got
his struggles and frustrations
just like a president of the united
states has struggles and frustration
sometimes but he's still
coming to work every day
he's still working to bring about change
every single day
just like
our attorney general
comes to work every single day
just like john lewis
every single day gets up it doesn't
matter whether he's in the majority of
the minority he's going to speak the
truth he's going to tell everybody what
he believes
and those stories should remind us
what brought us here
why
why did we seek a life of public service
why did we get involved
it wasn't just to
come to a gala
i mean it's nice everybody looks nice
but
you know it wasn't to cash in after
service
we may not have hitchhiked across the
country but
but everybody at some point we felt that
same tug that same voice in our heads
telling us
stand up
speak out
try to make a difference
remember what you know to be true what
you know to be just what you know to be
fair and be willing to fight it and
don't be timid about it
and maybe sometimes it's not going to
work out right away but if you stay at
it again and again and again and you do
not waver eventually we make a
difference
that's important
because while all our challenges are
different from the ones faced by
previous generations
we're going to need the same courage of
a robert avery
or a bayard rustin or a joyce ladner
all those marchers
from 50 years ago the same desire to get
involved the same courage
to make our voices heard
to stand up for whether it's quality
healthcare or good education or our
children's safety or
equal opportunity
we're gonna have to keep marching
and
i'm proud that i'll be
at least for the next three and a half
years here in washington and then a
whole lot of years after that i'm gonna
be marching with you god bless you
everybody thank you
you